topping tonight's know and tell Gwen
gets her Christmas wish
together for three years it's the first
time Blake's appeared in one of Gwen's
music videos
[Music]
looking super domestic and yeah we see
that diamond ring on that finger the
video for you make it feel like
Christmas could be teasing their future
but a source tells ET the couple is not
rushing to walk down the aisle they have
talked about marriage and even having
their own child but both plans are on
hold to appreciate what they have now
next the runaway bachelor every time I
put myself under 20 of man tears in this
just released promo but also a big
mystery
what makes Colton bolt home
[Music]
my god
Colton's going to be good TV and that is
the reason we chosen Chris Harrison
tells us the 26 year olds virginity
triggers the waterworks he got emotional
about when he was in the NFL and having
to fake it you could lose your virginity
this week
finally Frankie Muniz is engaged the
dancing juniors host proposed to
girlfriend of two and a half years Paige
price during a paper lantern launch at
an Arizona Fairgrounds she captioned
these pics I truly cannot wait to be
your wife she wants to marry me we can
do it right now
Paige got a little embarrassed when we
put Muniz on the spot last fall she's
amazing she was here
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]